men live a harder life than women and I
got data here to show you now obviously
this upsets a lot of different people
saying Pat how could you say something
like that blanket statement men live a
harder life than women yes praise for
impact whether you're gonna like it or
not wait till the end if you do get
value out of this and you say this is
kind of a good point he's making give it
a thumbs up subscribe to the channel if
not go watch a different video okay so
let's get right into it so based on a
research done DNA research by Dr
Baumeister he explains that in today's
human population is descended from twice
as many women as men now what does this
mean in the history of mankind 80
percent of women have reproduced and
have had kids only 40 percent of men
have ever reproduced so 80 percent women
40 men what does this mean that means
four out of five women reproduce only
two out of five men reproduce now why is
this so when we were looking at this
thing here we said let's look at data
let's look at some of the stuff that we
have access to right now it could be
Tinder and then let's look at what women
look for in men in a short-term
relationship and what women look for in
Men in long-term relationship and then
you get to make a decision for yourself
on how to increase your market value so
according to Tinder this is what you get
on how many women swipe right versus how
many men swipe right if you've never
been on Tinder like I've never been on
Tinder swiping right means you're
interested in this person swiping
leftists I don't have any interest when
it comes down to men men swipe right 53
of the time that means they're
interested 47 percent of the time they
say nope I'm not interested however for
women you ready ladies this is you now
okay this represents your number
according to Tinder you ready women only
swipe right five percent of the time 95
percent of the time you say I am not
interested swipe left a rejection to the
man so if you're a guy watching this at
the same path I'm on these dating gaps
and I gotta take this absolutely sucks
because I'm trying to get a relationship
well let me give you some more bad news
before we go tell you how to measure
short-term and long-term value we found
this chart showing in the attractiveness
of how attractive you are in the women
category like are you in the 80
percentile 10 percentile 90 percentile
how many men are still interested in a
woman that's this percentile
attractiveness so it's a little bit of a
crazy chart but I'm going to put it up
and we'll go through this together so
here's what it is if you look at the
charge you see the female advantage to
male Advantage right on the left it says
male attractiveness percentile right on
the bottom it says female attractiveness
percentile so let's look at the left if
you are in the top 20 of male
attractiveness you have only available
to you roughly 20 of women that you can
compete for okay now for women if you're
in the bottom 20 of attractiveness you
still have access to eighty percent of
men that would be interested in you of
course if you're in 100 it's 100 of
you're the best looking guy you're like
a Brad Pitt for your Rachel McAdams
everybody is interested you're at the
100 percentile right so if you look at
this it's quite depressing because if
you're in the bottom 20 of men in
attractiveness if you look how small
that is you're only dealing with two to
three percent of women if that means one
in every 50 women that's your pull on
who to choose from so you you may watch
us and say Pat is this supposed to be a
motivational Monday video there's
nothing motivational about this I
totally get it but you're either going
to watch this and you're going to say
screw these stats I'm gonna go have some
more chips and cheesecake and quit my
job and sit here and play video games
all day or are you gonna say I better
get my act together so what are women
looking for short term and what are
women looking for long term let's look
at the data women looking for short-term
relationship versus long-term
relationship on six different criterias
one is looks one is resources meaning
how much money success you have three is
your game four is your personality five
is your status and six is your age looks
is 35 of decision making process
resources only me six percent game is
thirty percent that's the second most
personality is nine percent status is
thirteen percent and an H whatever seven
percent now if they're looking for a
long-term relationship priorities change
when it comes down to looks it drops
from 35 to 15 okay when it comes down to
resources it goes from six percent to
twenty seven percent when it comes down
to game it drops from Thirty to seven
when it comes down to personality it
goes up from 9 to 18. they know they
have to deal with a personality long
term short term I don't care how
annoying you are you're handsome you got
game long term main your personality is
annoying so personality has a lot to do
with it then you have status goes from
13 to 23 percent and an age goes from
seven percent to ten percent so there's
a couple different ways you're going to
be listening to this you're going to
watch is going to be discouraged you're
going to watch this and saying okay
maybe I need to change my Approach let
me give you an idea when I started
working I'm working Stanley Dean with
her and they said well the profile of
the clients we're looking for is those
that are million dollars or higher back
then it was a half a million or a
quarter million but it was a million
dollars or higher that's the clientele
you got to be looking for and I sat
there and I'm like how the hell am I
going to meet millionaires my dad's a
cashier at a 99 Cent Store I don't have
a four-year degree I don't have a
two-year degree I know nothing about
money my parents have never owned a 401k
never owned the stock we've always
rented I've never lived in a house you
want me to go find million Auto accounts
how the hell am I going to find it I
just got out of the military here people
in the military are broke my friends go
to nightclubs how am I going to find all
this money right so I could have said
that and said you know what that's right
financial industry is not for me I'm out
or I could have sat there and said how
can I get into the market who do I need
to become to get into the market that I
want to become right and I made my
adjustments I was 22 years old 23 years
old just got out of the army we go to
the club my friends like Pat I found
this book it's called The Game Neil
Strauss watch these pickup lines I'm
going to use with the girls we go out
first you treat them this way you do
that you do this and then he got the
girls like oh I'm like well our style in
the military with similar to Weight I've
just never read before but it was
effective but what were we doing who are
we getting together with short-term
relationships right so look some of you
are watching this you're getting one or
two reactions you're discouraged you're
saying okay now at least I know what
they're looking for when you're a
businessman and you run a company you're
gonna have three different types of
clients low ticket item products you're
selling 99 Cents eight bucks 28 bucks 89
you got mid ticket item thousand dollars
fifty thousand dollars you got high
ticket on for example I'm selling a
rental apartment at Oakwood Apartments
four grand a month I'm selling a rental
apartment right middle one I'm selling
600 000 houses I'm selling multi-million
dollar homes right in this example if
you as a man want to have more options
and saying your clientele I want to have
a pool of bigger options of women to
choose from who do I need to become to
be able to sell two million dollar homes
okay what language do I need to speak to
get the client that's about to sell
their 2 million dollar home to look at
me and say this guy can sell this 2
million dollar home who do I need to
become what language do I need to have
how do I need to present myself how much
capability skill said what do I need to
do to increase my market value this is
why a lot of people 95 of people in
sales don't make it because they get
discouraged because they don't want to
become the person they need to be to
sell those products to the clientele in
that market the same thing goes with
this if you watch this and you said well
if it's 40 of men reproduce but 80
percent of women reproduce if the
options are that how do I become in the
top 20 percentile and if I'm chasing all
these short-term women the short-term
women I'm chasing they're looking for
only physical and they're only looking
for game they're not really value and
personality or for me to be somebody
where I am somebody that has status or
resources I can go fix those things now
if you're watching this insane you can
fix yourself physically and get in shape
maybe change your diet you can be
somebody at whatever company you're
working at if you're a person that's got
a voice you become a leader somebody
that's doing what you got status if
you're somebody that has a personality
you're afraid you're shy maybe you show
your personality a little bit more if
you want to go watch some of the old
tape videos there's a part of him that
he will shy if you look at the younger
version of them a lot out of the people
that end up having big personalities at
one point they were kind of to
themselves and then boom they break out
of their shell and they say oh my gosh I
never knew this existed in this guy you
have that but you got to tap into it
okay so now look obviously a lot of this
is directed to man I'm gonna talk to
women a little bit and you this could
also apply to men but here's what I have
to say about this because some people
are like you don't even know what you're
talking about I dare you to live a day
and walk a day in my life and all this
other stuff totally get it here's what I
do believe in there are a lot of men who
are bitter towards women and some of the
bitterness from mentors women is I gave
everything for her and she did this and
she went with that guy and she left me
okay cool yep that happens and then the
other one is I gave everything to him
and he did this and he left and it's all
his fault okay no problem just so you
know it takes two to make a thing go
right but it also takes sometimes two to
make a thing go wrong you made the
choice I made the choice some
relationship didn't work what part of
the role did I play in this thing here
and I'll man up and I'll take it the
same with you one of the ladies that
commented I'm known this lady for about
eight or ten years and I remember when
she chose career over her marriage and
her kids and she said I'm gonna go this
route to choose career over kids I said
listen man I totally get it Mary
sometime doesn't work out I've been
married now 13 years going on 14 years
we take marriage one year at a time it's
a very hard thing to do it is not easy
you can control what you do sometimes
you can't control what the other side
does and No One Ever Knows the whole
entire story to any marriage but she
specifically said I am choosing my
career because I want to compete with
the men above me in this sector that she
was in over my marriage and over my kids
I said I don't recommend it to do it for
that reason I have to do it she did
today she is so bitter but who's she bit
her at her husband her kids her
competitors the industry or her choice
it's pretty bad when you're bitter
towards really the choice you made
nobody put a gun to your head do you
know how many times I've been annoyed
with a decision I've made and I'm so
annoyed with myself no one knows about
it but I know I made the choice and I'm
bitter towards myself for making a bad
choice that happens to the best of us so
all this that we're talking about this
is really over younger men and younger
women this topic here that we're talking
about for some of you that are watching
that you're a little older and you're
frustrated about this totally get it but
you made the choice nobody forced you to
do it for the most part so if you get
value out of this video agree or
disagree but if you got value out of
this video give us a thumbs up
subscribe to the channel and if you want
to watch another video I did a video
titled the rise up week man if you've
never seen this before click here to
watch it take care everybody bye-bye
foreign
[Music]